all right let's take you live now to
Atlanta Georgia where the district
attorney involved in the latest
indictments of Donald Trump and his team
is speaking there following those
earlier indictments let's just listen
into what she has the prosecutors and
investigators who have worked diligently
on the investigation of criminal
attempts to interfere in the
administration of Georgia's 2020
presidential election
today based on information developed by
that investigation a Fulton County grand
jury returned a true bill of indictment
charging 19 individuals with violations
of Georgia law
arising from a criminal conspiracy to
overturn the results of the 2020
presidential election in this state
the indictment includes 41 felony counts
and is 97 pages long
please remember that everyone in charge
in this bill of indictment is Presumed
Innocent
specifically the indictment brings
felony charges against
Donald John Trump
Rudolph William Louis Giuliani
John Charles Eastman
Mark Randall medals
John cheese bro
Jeffrey Clark
Jenna Lynn Ellis
Ray Stallings Smith III
Robert David Chile
Michael a Roman
David James Schaefer
Sean Micah treasure Steele
Stephen cliffguard Lee
Harrison William Prescott Floyd
trayvion C cootie
Sydney Catherine Powell
Kathleen Austin Latham
Scott Graham Hall
and Misty Hampton also known as Emily
Misty Hayes
every individual charged in the
indictment is charged with one count of
violating Georgia's racketeer influenced
and corrupt organizations Act
through participation in a criminal
Enterprise in Fulton County Georgia and
elsewhere
to accomplish the illegal goal of
allowing Donald J Trump
to seize the presidential term of office
beginning on January 20th 21.
specifically the participants in
association took various actions in
Georgia and elsewhere
to block the county of the votes of the
presidential electors who were certified
as the winners of Georgia's 2020 general
election
as you examine the indictment you will
see acts that are identified as overtax
and those that are identified as
predicate acts sometimes called acts of
racketeering activity
overt acts are not necessarily crimes
under Georgia law in isolation
but are alleged to be acts taken in
furtherance of the conspiracy
many occurred in Georgia
and some occurred in other jurisdictions
and are included because the grand jury
believes they were part of the illegal
effort to overturn the results of
Georgia's 2020 presidential election
the acts identified as predicate Acts or
acts of racketeering activity are crimes
that are alleged to have been committed
in furtherance of the criminal
Enterprise
a racketeering activity are also charged
as separate counts in the indictment
against those who are alleged to have
committed them
all elections in our nation are
administered by these states
which are given the responsibility of
ensuring a fair process
and an accurate counting of the votes
that includes elections for presidential
electors Congress State officials and
local offices
the state's role in this process is
essential to the functioning of our
democracy
Georgia like every state has laws that
allow those who believe that results of
an election are wrong whether because of
intentional wrongdoing or unintentional
error to challenge those results in our
state courts
the indictment alleges that rather than
abide abide by Georgia's legal process
for election challenges the defendants
engaged in a criminal racketeering
Enterprise to overturn Georgia's
presidential election result
subsequent to the indictment as is the
normal process in Georgia law the the
grand jury issued arrest warrants for
those who are charged
I am giving the defendants the
opportunity to voluntarily surrender no
later than noon on Friday the 25th day
of August 2023.
I remind everyone here that an
indictment is only a series of
allegations based on a grand jury's
determination of probable cause to
support the charges
it is now the duty of my office to prove
these charges in the indictment Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt at trial
I would like to take a moment to thank
thank the Superior Court Clerk Shea
Alexander and her staff for staying late
and making sure that this indictment was
processed I would also like to thank the
men and women of sheriff labot's office
for keeping the courthouse open but most
importantly for keeping us safe over the
weeks and months that have led up to
this indictment and for what I know they
will continue to do to keep us safe
we also want to thank the Atlanta police
department and other law enforcement
Partners who have worked with the
sheriff to keep us safe I will now take
a very limited number of questions prior
uh to going to sleep
the mandatory minimum when it comes to
Rico charges whether it's serviceable by
probation or how that might plan the
RICO charges has time that you have to
serve so it is not a probated sentence
what is the timetable for the trial as
you know in this jurisdiction trials are
set by the judges
um and so it will be the judge that sets
the date of the trial this office will
be success submitting a proposed
scheduling order within this week
however that will totally be at the
discretion of the judge
[Music]
I don't have any desire to be first or
last I want to try him and be respectful
for our sovereign states we do want to
move this case along and so we will be
asking for a proposed order that occurs
a trial date within the next six months
um there was an earlier today there was
a fictitious document according to the
Fulton County clerk's office that was
circulated online the charges against
former president Donald Trump those that
fictitious document uh matched exactly
the charges that we now see in this
indictment can you tell us more about
that document leak because now you have
a former president's lawyers who are
saying this is diplomatic of a serious
problem with your office no I can't tell
you anything about um what you refer to
what I can tell you is that we had a
grand jury here in Fulton County they
deliberated till almost eight o'clock if
not right after eight o'clock an
indictment was returned it was true
build and you now have an indictment I
am not an expert on Clerks duties
um or even administrative duties I
wouldn't know how to work that system
and so I'm not going to speculate next
question
in these cases
do I intend to try the 19 defendants in
this indictment together yes
[Music]
I'm not going to discuss our
investigation at this time
made by former president
I make decisions in this office based on
the facts and the laws the law is
completely nonpartisan that's how
decisions are made in every case to date
this office has indicted since I've been
sitting as a district attorney over 12
000 cases this is the 11th Rico
indictment we followed the same process
we look at the facts we look at the law
and we bring charges
[Music]
so you're watching live pictures there
from Atlanta Georgia Fanny Willis The
Fulton County district attorney giving
us some more details of those
indictments handed down she said those
named in the indictment attempted to
interfere with the administration
process of the Georgia 2020 presidential
election results she said 19 people have
been charged in connection with
violation of Georgia's election law she
said 41 felony counts were brought 97
pages long so quite a substantial
document she named uh all uh the um
defendants including former president
Trump Rudy Giuliani his lawyer and Mark
Meadows the former white house chief of
staff she reminded the press conference
that indictments are a series of
allegations and that they are all
innocent until proven guilty so live
pictures there of that press conference
coming from Atlanta Georgia now the
former president's campaign team had
just release this statement on Trump's
social media platform truth social
attacking the Georgia prosecutor leading
the investigation over election
interference it says Georgia's radical
Democrat district attorney Fanny Willis
is a rabid partisan who is campaigning
and fundraising
on a platform of Prosecuting president
Trump through these bogus indictments a
quick response from Trump there John
hendron joins us live now from Atlanta
John so interestingly we got some more
detail there from Fanny Willis The
Fulton County D.A about these
indictments what more did she have to
say
well she outlined a widespread
conspiracy she said every one of those
19 people who are accused of crimes was
accused of playing a role in a massive
conspiracy to steal the presidential
election in the state of Georgia those
charges included such things as forgery
making false verbal statements making
false written statements harassing and
intimidating poll workers and there was
also a breach of data in Coffee County
Georgia in which
people who worked in the election office
invited in the pro-trump officials who
came in and then physically scanned
those votes so that's included among the
charges they're saying that was an
illegal seizure so this is a
wide-ranging conspiracy and you know in
the U.S you don't actually in a
presidential election uh directly elect
the president you elect that person
through electors and what what they're
alleging happened in Georgia is that the
Trump team tried to substitute its own
slate of electors who they hoped would
then turn the election for Donald Trump
instead of Joe Biden and there's no
precedent for having done that so those
people are named as members of this
wide-ranging conspiracy but also among
those people are people who pressured uh
officials in Georgia in order to get
them to help them with this conspiracy
there's Rudolph Giuliani who testified
in front of the Georgia Senate saying
that there was an attempt to steal this
election specifically naming poll
workers and showing a heavily edited
video in which he said they were handing
each other a thumb drive with votes that
they were going to insert when those two
poll workers were asked exactly what
they were handing to each other in that
very fuzzy video they said it was a mint
um John I think I'm right and saying
there was also one count of racketeering
this is an extremely serious charge
isn't it
that racketeering charge is the most
serious if you look on the category of
what those charges are that one says a
serious felony all the rest just say
felonies why is it serious it comes with
a penalty of 20 years in prison a
minimum penalty of five years in prison
so with a charge like that hanging over
people's head you can bet that some
people have flipped and reported on the
for president's activities and that some
Others May likely either Flip or try to
do so in order to reduce the charges
against them and get rid of that very
serious charge for someone like Rudolph
Giuliani who is an old man now that is a
death sentence so a very serious charge
and one that's kind of uh a trademark
for this particular prosecutor she also
used that racketeering charge against
the Atlanta school system alleging a
widespread cheating scandal that uh hurt
particularly minority students that
racketeering charge which is usually
used only to pursue organized crime in
this case is being used rather
creatively but creatively in a way that
this particular District district
attorney has done before it remains to
be seen whether in a case this high
profile that will be effective John just
a quick one before you go I mean let's
remind our viewers this is now Trump's
fourth set of indictments remind us
quickly of the other three and how is
all of this likely then to affect his
Run for the White House next year just
quickly John
well the quick answer to that is the
more he gets indicted the higher his
poll numbers go among Republicans and
the more money he raises it's a perverse
thing but that's what's going on but he
also has a case in New York state
another state case in which he's accused
of a scheme to pay off and uh with hush
money a former porn star then he's got a
federal charge in Washington uh for his
activities and trying to overturn the
election one in Florida also Federal
mishandling documents and then you've
got this wide-ranging case in Georgia
those will some of them perhaps be
finished before the election perhaps be
finished after but none of them
disqualifies him under the U.S
Constitution for being president there's
an argument to be made that if someone
commits treason they are not allowed to
be president but these crimes aren't
specifically listed as treason so that
would be contested in court as well okay
John hendron live us there in Atlanta
Georgia John thank you